[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und christian sievers
guten abend in allen es geht aktuell um
nichts weniger als um den schutz von
leben und gesundheit oder um es mit dem
bundesverfassungsgericht zu sagen um
gemeinwohl ziele von überragender
bedeutung deutschlands hüterinnen und
hüter der grundrechte haben den
regierenden heute einen weiten spielraum
gegeben bei der bekämpfung einer
wütenden pandemie dazu gleich mehr erst
die frage wie nutzen die regierenden
diesen spielraum jetzt ganz konkret und
vor allem ganz schnell die antwort wird
erschwert durch die tatsache dass da
heute nicht nur 16 bundesländer zusammen
geschaltet waren sondern auch
gewissermaßen zwei bundesregierungen
eine bundeskanzlerin fast a d und ein
bundeskanzler in spe am ende steht die
ankündigung da werde einiges kommen
details noch unklar erstmal kommt
übermorgen eine weitere konferenz ich
habe gleich eine menge fragen leif randt
olaf scholz aber erst fast heikes lanz
geht diesen polit tag inmitten der
vierten welle zusammen
es ist der tag an dem die ampelkarten
ihren widerstand aufgeben getrieben von
den hohen infektionszahlen von
hilferufen aus den intensivstationen und
nun auch noch vom
bundesverfassungsgericht die korona
notbremse war rechtens die liberalen die
dagegen geklagt hatten enttäuscht wenn
das höchste deutsche gericht eine
entscheidung getroffen hat dann
respektieren wir diese entscheidung
selbstverständlich das ist für uns
völlig klar es dauert nicht lange schon
setzt ein wettlauf um verschärfte
maßnahmen ein im kanzleramt eine
video-konferenz mit den länderchefs bei
denen der altkanzler vielen forderungen
der union nach gibt das gerade erst
verabschiedete infektionsschutzgesetz
soll noch einmal verschärft werden es
gibt ein klares verständnis dass nicht
nur die maßnahmen am 15 dezember nicht
auslaufen dürfen sondern dass die länder
alle instrumente in die hand bekommen
sollen um diese krise zu meistern
rückenwind für das team vorsicht gestern
noch die botschaft die lokal verhängten
einschränkungen
bayern zeigten wirkung die
infektionszahlen gingen etwas zurück
nach dem urteil heute fordert der
bayerische ministerpräsident gleich eine
bundesweite notbremse ich denke das was
heute auf den weg gebracht wurde es muss
jetzt noch finalisiert werden es muss
geschlossen werden das ist auf jeden
fall so was wie ein crooner paket und
ein stück weit auch in den notbremse der
ruf nach einheitlichen maßnahmen das
infektionsgeschehen ist jedoch regional
unterschiedlich die höchsten zahlen
verzeichnet sachsen schleswig-holstein
dagegen liegt weit unter dem
bundesdurchschnitt nicht jeder ist mit
dem vorhandenen werkzeugkasten
unzufrieden auch nicht bei der union
ich habe immer gesagt dass wir keine
konferenz brauchen weil wir das
notwendige rüstzeug in schleswig
holstein haben unsere entscheidungen zu
treffen wir haben immer angekündigt dass
es verschärfung geben kann ganz anders
die lage in baden württemberg
vorstellbar zweig oder zweig plus für
den einzelhandel und veranstaltungen für
ganz deutschland kontakt beschränkungen
für ungeimpfte und geimpfte ziemlich
sicher werden wir folgendes machen
fußballspiele
sportgroßveranstaltungen werden nur noch
ohne publikum stattfinden wir werden
freizeitbetriebe wie clubs und
diskotheken schließen scholz soll sich
heute nun doch für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ausgesprochen haben zuerst
aber soll general carsten bräuer mit
einer schnellen eingreiftruppe das impf
tempo steigern er leitet künftig den
corona krisenstab im kanzleramt
wir sind uns einig darin dass wir bis
ende des jahres bis zu 30 millionen
impfung in deutschland haben wollen
sowohl booster impfung als auch weitere
erst und 25 am donnerstag treffen sich
alle beteiligten wieder im kanzleramt
und wollen zu festen verabredungen
kommen mitten in der vierten welle
olaf scholz ist der designierte
bundeskanzler der heute ganz vehement
spürt wie ein land von ihm
entscheidungen erwartet obwohl noch gar
nicht im amt ist oder genannte scholz
guten abend herr sievers ja haben sie
dieses gefühl dass das land von ihnen
entscheidungen erwartet und zwar schnell
es wird entscheidungen geben und die
sind ja auch gut vorbereitet die erste
haben wir heute miteinander
gemeinsam voran gebracht es wird ein
krisenstab im kanzleramt geben general
carsten bräuer wird den leuten und wir
werden die größte herausforderung damit
gemeinsam angehen vor der wir stehen wie
kriegen wir das hin dass in ganz kurzer
zeit bis zu 30 millionen frauen und
männer geimpft oder mit eine
auffrischungsimpfung versehen werden das
ist eine große große herausforderung für
alle länder für alle landkreise für die
städte und gemeinden und da müssen wir
zusammenstehen das haben wir jetzt neu
aufgestellt und organisiert und es wird
die größte operation die wir seit langer
zeit auf den weg gebracht haben gut dass
das jetzt gemeinsam geht und das ist
eine erste ganz entscheidende maßnahme
ja nur dass sie sagen dass wir wollen
dass bis weihnachten machen deswegen ist
ja noch niemand geimpft wir haben
aktuell eine impfquote die gerade mal
die hälfte erreicht wenn man dass man
auf den tag unterbricht das müssten
jetzt wenn sie auf 30 millionen bis
weihnachten kommen wollen jeden tag 1,25
millionen impfungen seien im moment
haben wir nicht mal die hälfte wie
konkret wollen sie denn das impf tempo
steigern vor allem vor dem vor dem
hintergrund dass es ja auch aktuell
bereits überall klemmt und hakt ihre
frage ist fast schon die antwort weil
das so ist müssen wir jetzt etwas tun
das anders ist und sich von dem
unterscheidet was in der vergangenheit
gemacht worden ist es müssen alle räder
ineinander greifen damit das gut
funktioniert und deshalb habe ich das
sehr präzise vorbereitet und ich bin
herrn breuer sehr sehr dankbar dass er
diese wichtige aufgabe für unser land
übernimmt das ist jemand der dafür steht
und der auch sein ganzes geschick und
seine große erfahrung einbringen wird
denn hier geht es ja darum dass wir
zusammenarbeiten dass die logistik
stimmt und dass all die fragen die sie
stellen und die auch tausende andere
verantwortliche in deutschland stellen
geklappt dass sie kriege ich meinen
impfstoff wie klar ich das organisiert
beantwortet weil es absolut nur das
würde doch die alte regierung die
bisherige regierung genauso
unterschreiben dass alle räder
ineinander greifen müssen dass die
logistik funktionieren muss ist es jetzt
einfach damit getan dass da ein
bundeswehr-general das kommando führt
nein wir werden viele weitere dinge
machen müssen aber da es ist natürlich
eine ganz ganz große operation und dann
geht es ja darum dass wir viele weitere
maßnahmen ergreifen wir haben schon
überall beschlossen dass es zwei geben
soll das möchte ich gerne flächendeckend
haben das nur geimpfte und genesene
gaststätten aufsuchen können oder
veranstaltungen wir wollen zusätzlich
eröffnen dass das auch für den handel
gilt außer für den täglichen bedarf auch
das ist etwas worauf wir uns sicher
verständigen werden wir werden private
kontakte einschränken das heißt
ungeimpfte werden sich nur noch mit sehr
wenigen treffen können bis zu zwei
personen außerhalb des eigenen
haushaltes das ist das was jetzt
diskutiert wird wenn wir wollen
sicherstellen dass bei
großveranstaltungen stärkere
beschränkungen umgesetzt werden wir
wollen sicherstellen dass wenn die
inzidenz hoch sind zum beispiel clubs
und diskotheken nicht mehr weiter
betrieben werden können in dieser zeit
in der wir jetzt sind an den schulen
sollen überall masken getragen werden
und dann haben wir natürlich auch die
beiden großen weiteren maßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht die jetzt wichtig sind zum
beispiel das ist ein einrichtung so
viele schützenswerte sind in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen krankenhäuser
für alle beschäftigten eine impf
verpflichtung geben wird und wir bringen
jetzt auch noch auf den weg dass der
deutsche bundestag ein gesetz über
gesetzentwürfe abstimmt die eine
allgemeine impfpflicht scholz auf den
weg
müssen wir die leute sonst verstehen
dass wir das unbedingt auseinander
drosseln da war am anfang bis zur
allgemeine impfpflicht viel von dem wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe was sie
heute im grundsatz besprochen haben und
dann am donnerstag tatsächlich
verpflichtend beschließen werden korrekt
das sind die dinge die heute wirklich
sehr gut diskutiert wurde denn ich
glaube wir müssen aus den stil ändern
indem wir über corona politik reden ja
es kann nicht sein dass jeden tag jemand
eine neue meldung produziert
irgendwelche vorschläge machen wie
sollen die bürgerinnen und bürger da
noch durchblicken donnerstag für scholz
wird das dann alles tatsächlich auch so
beschlossen werden zum beispiel was sie
vorhin ankündigten zweig im einzelhandel
außer bei lebensmitteln das bin ich
sicher wird das ergebnis seien dafür war
der konsens zu eindeutig und das ist
sehr gut denn ich habe mich sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass es so kommen wird ok
dann kommen wir zu dem anderen was sie
vorhin auch kurz angerissen haben sie
wollen eine allgemeine impfpflicht haben
sie heute gesagt wie stellen sie sich
die denn konkret vor wer nicht geimpft
ist wird irgendwann bestraft in
deutschland oder wie soll das laufen wir
haben ja jetzt schon allgemeine im
pflichten zum beispiel bei masern sind
die in bestimmten bereich
vorgeschriebenen auch für andere
bereiche gilt das und das ist jetzt doch
so dass die lage sich geändert hat wir
haben es nicht geschafft dass
ausreichend viele bürgerinnen und bürger
sich geimpft haben sehr viele haben das
und weil es aber nicht genug sind ist es
so dass wir in der lage sind in der wir
heute uns befinden denn von denen die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen wird es
ja nicht nur viele betreffen das sie
selber irgendwann eine infektion
erreicht sondern das hat ja auch folgen
für das infektionsgeschehen im ganzen
land für die belastung in den
krankenhäusern krankenhäusern auf den
intensivstationen und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir sagen unter diesen
umständen kann und muss eine solche
entscheidung getroffen denn ich bin
dafür ich bin aber auch dafür dass das
auf basis von entscheidungen aus dem
bundestag geschieht wo jeder abgeordnete
nach seinem gewissen entscheidet aus
ihrer sicht wann kommt die dann oder
wann soll die dann kommen sie muss zu
einem zeitpunkt kommen wo auch jeder der
jetzt sich entschließt sich impfen zu
lassen und bisher noch nicht geimpft ist
zwei impfungen realistisch bekommen
haben kann deshalb finde ich wäre es
richtig wenn sie für alle gilt ab anfang
februar anfang märz und sie schlagen
auch vor eine auffrischimpfung sag ich
jetzt einfach mal nach sechs monaten
weil man ansonsten als bereits geimpfter
dann doch wieder wie ein ungeimpfter
behandelt werden würde wir diskutieren
über die frage wann es so ist dass die
alte impfung nicht mehr den
vollständigen impfschutz gewährleistet
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sagen uns dass das nach
sechs monaten dringend erforderlich ist
eine neue impfung zu bekommen und das
nach einer weiteren zeit das dann nicht
mehr wirksam ist deshalb diskutiert zum
beispiel auch die europäische union
gegenwärtig darüber dass nach neun
monaten dieser vollständigen impfschutz
dann nicht mehr gegeben ist und ich
glaube das ist etwas wo wir uns
einklinken sollten und wo wir einen weg
finden sollten wie wir diese idee an wir
vermitteln dass es nicht getan ist mit
der zweiten impfung sondern dass
irgendwann die nächste kommt muss wir
haben dann allerdings als gemeinschaft
die städte und gemeinden landkreise die
länder und der bund die verpflichtung
eben auch zu ermöglichen das realistisch
tun zu können da soll ja niemand vor
eine unlösbare aufgabe gestellt sein
jetzt war das urteil aus karlsruhe heute
rückenwind für alle die mehr wollen die
weitergehende einschränkungen wollen und
zwar schnell jetzt gibt aber natürlich
auch die andere seite in deutschland
viele die angst haben sorge haben dass
ein locker und wieder kommen könnte dass
ihre geschäfte wieder probleme bekommen
und dass die kinder nicht mehr in die
schule gehen können gibt es herr scholz
an diesem tag irgendetwas was sie
kategorisch ausschließen können wo sie
sagen das wird garantiert nicht kommen
solche sätze sollte man wenig sagen eine
pandemie die immer wieder neue wollten
schlägt und deshalb uns auch vor neue
herausforderungen stellt aber es ist
klar was wir jetzt tun müssen und das
ist dass wir dafür sorgen dass wir uns
gewissermaßen aus der jetzigen welle
heraus impfen und es kann auch geschehen
wenn wir jetzt gemeinsam vorgehen die
bürgerinnen und bürger die
verantwortlichen in den städten und
gemeinden den landkreisen den ländern
und wenn wir das schaffen dann werden
wir eine bessere situation haben und
darum geht es darum jetzt die große
anstrengung stolz wie schlimm die
situation ist das haben sie gerade
nochmal mehrfach gesagt jetzt ist es
allerdings so dass wir immer noch nicht
wissen wer der künftige
gesundheitsminister in einer künftigen
bundesregierung denn sein sollte das ist
er eigentlich so nimmt man das zumindest
als normalbürger an eigentlich das
ressort was das erste sein müsste dass
besetzt wird kann man denn davon
ausgehen wenn alle im moment karl
lauterbach karl lauterbach nennen sie
sich aber doch sehr viel zeit lassen
dass es dann eben nicht karl lauterbach
wird sondern vielleicht hamburgs
bürgermeister peter tschentscher
die regierung wird in der nächsten woche
ins amt kommt die kanzlerwahl findet im
deutschen bundestag statt und dann
werden alle ministerien und minister zur
gleichen zeit mit ihrer arbeit beginnen
und es ist deshalb völlig sicher dass
sie sich darauf verlassen können dass
anfang der nächsten woche alle männer
und frauen benannt sind die in die
nächste regierung eintreten werden und
dann glaube ich geht die arbeit los dass
wir uns gar nicht die zeit bis dahin
lassen sehen sie daran dass heute schon
entscheidung vorbereitet worden sind die
sich auch auf das künftige regierung
geschehen richten wie zum beispiel der
krisenstab über den wir eingangs
gesprochen haben sagt der designierte
bundeskanzler olaf scholz live im zdf
heute journal herr scholz vielen dank
schöner danke hin auch
noch nie in der nachkriegsgeschichte
dieses landes wurden die grundrechte so
sehr beschränkt wie zur bekämpfung
dieser pandemie so gesehen konnte man
durchaus ein bisschen nervös werden ob
der tatsache dass die richterinnen und
richter die diese grundrechte beschützen
und bewahren sollen fast zwei jahre
pandemie verstreichen ließen bis zu
ihrer ersten großen corona entscheidung
bis heute aus karlsruhe kommt jetzt
nachträglich der höchstrichterliche
segen für einige besonders umstrittene
beschränkungen zwischen den zeilen
markiert das verfassungsgericht aber
auch rote linien um was es konkret geht
und was das heißt für die zukunft der
leute an die zdf rechtsexperte nsar
attacke und günter neufeld
es geht um sie um ihr recht auf bildung
das im grundgesetz verankert ist sie
konnten über monate nicht gemeinsam
lernen
das ist viel langweiliger und
lernt irgendwie nicht so richtig die
bekämpfung der pandemie habe man auf den
rücken der kinder und jugendlichen
ausgetragen sagt seine mutter die seien
am wenigsten gefährdet durch corona
hätten aber unter den schulschließung
schwer gelitten
soziale kontakte wurden vernachlässigt
der korona speck selbst bei unseren
jüngsten wächst ja die die isolation
erzeugt angst und auch zum teil
depression deshalb gründeten sie an
ihrer schule in baden württemberg eine
initiative und vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu ziehen und
scheitern heute jeder mit die
entscheidung des gerichts sei aber
vertretbar und gut begründet mein
staatsrechtler franz mayer
das bundesverfassungsgericht in der tat
fest dass die kinder möglicherweise
nicht 3 bei der pandemie sind aber aus
sicht des bundesverfassungsgerichts sind
ausreichend anhaltspunkte da dass sie
einen beitrag zum infektionsgeschehen
leisten letztlich lässt es hier den
gesetzgeber den spielraum zu entscheiden
dass dieser kleine beitrag den die
kinder leisten eben ausreicht um hier
auch maßnahmen zu ergreifen in ihrer
entscheidung bewerten die richterinnen
und richter erstmals ausführlich die
korona politik nur schriftlich auf
diesen knapp 200 seiten prüfen sie neben
schulschließung auch ausgangs und
kontakt beschränkungen davon waren alle
menschen in deutschland betroffen auch
er stephan thomae fdp
bundestagsabgeordneter aus dem allgäu in
dieser ländlichen idylle nachts nicht
auf die menschenleere strasse zu dürfen
das war für ihn schlicht nicht
nachvollziehbar
die gefahr dass man zur nachtstunde
jemanden trifft den mann anstecken kann
ist viel geringer als das tas tagsüber
der fall ist durch die
verfassungsrichter sehen auch das anders
entscheiden heute das in einer äußersten
gefahrenlage der stadt sehr wohl auch
ausgangs und kontakt beschränkungen
verhängen darf
das gericht schaut sich auch die
nächtlichen ausgangssperren sehr genau
an kommt da zu der einschätzung dass es
sich nicht um freiheitsentziehung
handelt und geht im einzelnen auch sehr
detailliert auf die mögliche begründung
ein die natürlich von der regierung vom
staat vorgebracht wurde das nämlich auch
die nächtlichen ausgangssperren
insgesamt einen beitrag dazu leisten
können das infektionsgeschehen zu
reduzieren diese entscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts in die aktuelle
corona lage zu übersetzen das wird die
große herausforderung für den
gesetzgeber
unter dem strich ist die botschaft doch
recht klar die wirklich schwierigen
abwägung die muss der demokratisch
legitimierte gesetzgeber selber treffen
ein verweis auf angebliche
rechtsunsicherheit trägt hier nicht
schulen schließen kontakte beschränken
ausgang verbieten all das und noch
einiges mehr das grundgesetz lässt in
einer pandemie selbst schärfste
einschränkungen zu
im heute-journal update nachher hat nah
sein möchte mir fragen an den
bayerischen gesundheitsminister und das
thema kona bestimmt auch den
nachrichtenüberblick jetzt hier bei uns
mit kassel noch ist unklar wie gut die
existierenden impfstoffe gegen die
omikron variante wirken so geht der chef
des us herstellers moderner von einem
deutlich vermindern datenschutz aus
optimistischer äußerte sich bei und
ex-chef sahin es sei wahrscheinlich dass
die impfung auch weiterhin einen
deutlichen schutz vor schweren verläufen
biete klarheit werde man in rund zwei
wochen haben die nato warnt russland vor
einem angriff auf die ukraine und sie
will offenbar mögliche
reaktionsmöglichkeiten ausloten für
jegliche form von aggression müsse
russland einen preis zahlen das sagte
bundesaußenminister maß nach einem
treffen mit seinen nato-kollegen in
lettland hintergrund ist ein
ungewöhnlich großer aufmarsch russischer
truppen auch schwere waffen wurden
unweit der ukraine stationiert
kremlchef putin kritisierte im gegenzug
die militärpräsenz westlicher staaten an
der russischen grenze
in frankreich will der rechtsextreme
publizist erich sie nur für das
präsidentenamt kandidieren es sei an der
zeit frankreich zu retten sagte er in
einer videobotschaft
der 63-jährige ist für provokante
aussagen zum thema migration bekannt die
sich vor allem gegen muslime richten
schon zweimal wurde er wegen
volksverhetzung verurteilt
und dann noch ein urteil heute mit
grundsatz wirkung und gleichzeitig eine
premiere
der weltweit erste prozess der den
völkermord an den jesiden handelt das
oberlandesgericht frankfurt schreibt
damit rechtsgeschichte und zeigt
gleichzeitig wie sehr die welt noch
hinterher hinkt bei der aufarbeitung der
massaker der terror miliz islamischer
staat im irak im haupt siedlungsgebiet
der religionsgemeinschaft der jesiden
wurden tausende getötet fast eine halbe
million vertrieben beim prozess in
frankfurt ging es um den tod eines
versklavten jesidischen mädchens es ging
auch um die botschaft wer sich des
völkermordes schuldig macht sollte
nirgendwo sicher sein vor strafe susanna
santina
was sie erlebt hat sagt dahl können sie
niemals vergessen die esi den lebt seit
einigen jahren in deutschland als sie 17
jahre alt war über viele nie es
terroristen ihr dorf entführten sie wie
viele frauen und die haben mich noch mal
verkauft natürlich ich hatte angst und
ich war sehr traurig und
ich kann durch diese seite von meinem
leben vergessen ich versuche aber sehr
schwer
dal wurde von neun männern immer wieder
vergewaltigt bis sie irgendwann die
flucht gelang sie ist immer noch in
psychologischer behandlung
august 2014 je sieben fliehen vor ihr es
terroristen nur weniger reichen die
rettende flieger nordirak
unermesslich die brutalität der
angreifer
jüdische männer werden hingerichtet und
in massengräbern verscharrt tausende
jesiden werden versklavt
auch kljb sie denn als sklaven gemeinsam
mit ihrem kind des anhänger wurde in
frankfurt unter anderem wegen des
völkermords an den juden zu lebenslanger
haft verurteilt er soll die tochter der
isi den stunden lang bei 50 grad hitze
angekettet haben das mädchen verdurstete
qualvoll
seine taten seien teil des völkermord-
plan ist dass sie es so das gericht dank
des so genannten weltrechtsprinzip
konnte es das verfahren an sich ziehen
obwohl weder täter noch opfer deutsche
staatsangehörige sind und die tat nicht
in deutschland begangen wurde es ist
eine warnung für täter schwerster völker
straftaten dass sie zur verantwortung
gezogen werden können egal wo sie sich
aufhalten dass der angeklagte auch wegen
völkermords verurteilt wurde ist für je
sieben weltweit ein meilenstein
von historischer bedeutung denn es ist
das erste mal dass der straflosigkeit
gegen die jesiden ein ende gesetzt wird
auf deutschen boden und deswegen freuen
wir uns über dieses urteil
trauma psychologe jan kiesel hahn
betreut viele jüdische frauen auch diese
damals 16 jährige sie hatte sich selbst
mit benzin übergossen wollte sich
umbringen wie viele versklavten
vergewaltigung diese grausamkeit angehen
wollten dass sie sich eng an strom
netzen getan haben dass sie versucht
haben sich aufzuhängen die pulsadern zu
schneiden viele dieser frauen
sind natürlich schwer traumatisiert da
leidet sehr darunter dass ihre
vergewaltiger unbestraft blieben wir
haben viele sachen von deiner
weggenommen und ich finde warum die
leben kannst normal
wir haben gar nichts und wir versuchen
wieder familie haben vielleicht kinder
haben
da will alles dafür tun damit sie wieder
eine zukunft hat
immer noch werden mehr als 2800 jüdische
frauen und kinder vom irs gefangen
gehalten oder gelten als vermisst das
war heute ein entscheidender beginn
sagen völkerrechtsexperten was es jetzt
braucht sind weitere anklagen
nochmal kassel mit einem blick auf die
deutsche bahn und ihre beziehungen zur
politik da sieht der bundesrechnungshof
erhebliche interessenkonflikte
denn einige aufsichtsratsmitglieder der
bahn seien gleichzeitig
bundestagsabgeordnete oder
staatssekretäre damit seien sie sowohl
vertreter des geldgebers als auch das
geld empfängers die rechnungsprüfer
kritisieren auch eine mangelhafte
gewinnabführung an den bund und jetzt
schauen wir auf ein urteil das für
10.000 beschäftigte relevant sein dürfte
nämlich für die die wegen der korona
krise in die sogenannte kurzarbeit null
geschickt werden sprich die wochen- oder
monatelang gar nicht arbeiten ihnen kann
der jahresurlaub anteilig gekürzt werden
das hat das bundesarbeitsgericht
entschieden
schließlich werde der urlaubsanspruch an
der zahl der arbeitswilligen tage
bemessen und wir bleiben beim thema denn
mit der vierten corona welle ist die
zahl der kurzarbeiter wieder angestiegen
und nicht nur deshalb zeigt sich der
chef der bundesagentur für arbeit
scheele besorgt bei der präsentation der
novemberzahlen fand eher ungewöhnlich
deutliche worte frank bethmann ja
errechnet wird nicht damit dass wir vor
einem wirklich schweren winter stehen
würden er gehe inzwischen von einer
arbeitslosigkeit im nächsten jahr aus
und das obwohl der blick in den
rückspiegel heute noch sehr robust
ausfiel denn im november entwickelte
sich der arbeitsmarkt noch positiv zwei
millionen 317.000 menschen waren ohne
arbeit das sind 60.000 weniger als im
oktober nun sind wir es gewohnt dass der
chef der arbeitsagentur monatlich einen
überblick über die lage am arbeitsmarkt
gibt ungewöhnliche doch wie offen und
vehement scheele heute eine schubladen
fertige impfpflicht forderte ich glaube
das ist die einzige chance in diesem
jahr nicht noch einmal in so eine
furchtbare lage für menschen geschäfte
mitarbeiter unternehmer und eben auch
erkrankte zu kommen niedrige impfquote
hohe instanzen gefährdete existenzen das
alles würde zusammengehören und die
entwicklung bremsen so der chef der
arbeitsagentur die sorge vor der korona
variante um die kommen machte am abend
auch der wall street zu schaffen
fallende aktienkurse zuvor auch hier in
frankfurt der dax büßt 1,2 prozent oder
181 punkte ein nach einer leichten
erholung zum wochenstart ist sie also
wieder zurück die furcht vor der
pandemie
die börse frank
sechs spiele sechs siege mit dieser
makellosen bilanz verabschieden sich die
deutschen fußball-frauen in die
winterpause in der wm qualifikation
gewann die mannschaft von
bundestrainerin von tecklenburg auch ihr
letztes spiel des jahres gegen verfolger
portugal hier ist es am ende 3 zu 1 die
dfb frauen bauen ihre tabellenführung
damit aus und machen einen großen
schritt in richtung wm
frankreich kann pomp frankreich kein
parkhaus der präsident liebt historische
persönlichkeiten und emotionale reden
und er ist der einzige der entscheiden
darf wer hier geehrt wird hier im
pantheon dem ruhmestempel der nation in
paris wo das land seine unsterblichen
begraben hat 75 männer fünf frauen heute
wird josephine baker dort aufgenommen
die tänzerin entertainerin und
widerstandskämpferin als erste schwarze
sie hat mal gesagt die pariser haben mir
alles gegeben vor allem ihr herz eine
art zeigt eine denkwürdige zeremonie
einzug in frankreichs ruhmeshalle fast
ein halbes jahrhundert nach ihrem tod
ehrt die nation josephine baker trägt
symbolträchtig einen sarg ins pariser
pantheon
eine schwarze die schwarze verteidigt
hat war sie aber vor allem eine frau die
sich für alle menschen eingesetzt hat
amerikanerin französin mit 19 jahren
kommt josephine baker aus den usa nach
paris auf der bühne parodiert sie in
ihren tänzen rassistische fantasien sie
ist der star der annie voll der 20er
jahre
[Musik]
er verhöhnte all jenen die in ihr ein
wildes tier sehen wollten in völlig
überzeichneten auftritten gab sie das
wesen aus dem dschungel das führte dazu
dass die zuschauer begannen sie mit
anderen augen zu sehen und zu
respektieren
während des zweiten weltkriegs nutzt sie
diese prominenz für politische zwecke
inzwischen eingebürgerte französin
engagiert sie sich in der résistance
dafür bekommt sie später den orden der
französischen ehrenlegion
sie hat das leben meiner eltern und
meiner großeltern geprägt und für sie
verdient sie heute diesen platz
sie hat eine familie gegründet mit zwölf
kindern sämtliche hautfarben und
religionen
das ist ein akt der menschlichkeit der
offenheit der toleranz
die selbsternannte regenbogen familie
bewohnt ein schloss im südwesten
frankreichs josephine baker will allen
vorleben dass ein friedliches
zusammensein möglich ist unabhängig von
der herkunft die niemals über den wert
eines menschen entscheiden dürfe
wenn meine mutter heute noch leben würde
würde sie sehen dass es noch immer viele
formen von rassismus in frankreich steht
und in der welt aber das würde nicht
entmutigen
eine kämpferin und künstlerin
unermüdlich zieht es sie auf die bühne
josephine baker wird 68 jahre alt dass
frankreich sie nun zur heldin macht hat
im beginnenden präsidentschaftswahlkampf
politische symbolkraft sieht das
sinnieren das ist ein starkes signal in
der aktuellen migrationsdebatte einer
eingewanderten frau die sich in
frankreich integriert hat wird ins
pantheon aufgenommen
und gehört damit nun zu den großen der
französischen geschichte ein ruhmreicher
schlussakkord für josephine baker
[Musik]
eine homage sehr französisch damit
beenden will dieses heute journal
aber erst ihnen allen ein angenehm haben
[Musik]
guten abend morgen beginnt
meteorologisch der winter und da sind ja
besonders die temperaturen interessante
die entscheiden ja ob es nun regnet oder
schneit mit dem sturmtief daniel wird es
jetzt erst mal bilder aber wenn dieses
sturmtief am donnerstag dann das
baltikum erreicht haben wird wird es bei
uns in mitteleuropa schon gleich wieder
kälter in dieser nacht ist es aber erst
mal mild im nordwesten sinken die
temperaturen nicht unter 8 bis 4 grad
wird östlich der elbe in den
mittelgebirgen und in süddeutschland
geht es dagegen auf plus 3 bis minus 1
grad runter da reicht also überall noch
für kletter zumal aus den wolken dort
auch noch etwas schneeregen herauskommt
sonst fällt kräftiger regen und der wind
nimmt schon durch zu sie sehen hier sehr
schön dass tiefdruck zentrum über der
nordsee und bis morgen abend erreicht
dass etwa lübeck machen sie sich morgen
über tag also auf kräftige regenfälle
gefasst nur am alpenrand sehen sie mal
die sonne und anfänglich kann in
mecklenburg vorpommern auch noch ein
bisschen schnee dabei sagen in diesem
kräftigen südwestwind steigen die
temperaturen morgen hier in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen auf 4 grad am
rhein und auch auf den ostfriesischen
inseln sind es zehn grad und dem schnee
in den mittelgebirgen geht es an den
kragen durch diese milden temperaturen
durch den regen aber eben auch durch den
wind und es wird morgen wirklich nicht
nur stürmisch sondern an der
nordseeküste drohen sogar orkanböen bis
120 kilometer pro stunde am donnerstag
dreht der wind schon auf nordwestlichen
richtungen dann wird es kälter und der
samstag dann schon wieder will nämlich
wilder und windiger schönen abend